Brooklyn tailors came out of my
experience as a very frustrated consumer
we offer everything from fully bespoke
suits to our own ready-to-wear
collection I had no intention of going
in the fashion business originally it
just kind of drove me nuts why should
someone like myself not be able to go
out and find a suit that fit his needs
the right aesthetic a splash of color
here needs to be anchored by something
neutral here you know that became sort
of this obsession and the next thing I
knew I mean I was coming home from work
and fitting people and on a purely
word-of-mouth basis but you know there
wasn't a business my wife ran out she
kind of sat down with me and said we
need a name we need a website we're a
team and let's do this there's always a
lot of pressures as you grow to make
things that you may not feel right about
it can be very intimidating to walk into
a buyer meeting you know you'll get
requests to modify the fit of what you
do you'll get requests and modify the
fabric and you don't want to say no to
people you've got a whole treat of what
you know that you're about so if that
means Brooklyn tailors doesn't like this
color it's not to say we're not open to
trying new things we stopped being
ourselves we'll stop being compelling
will stop being worth people's time the
rate of growth has been kind of
mind-boggling we're talking about
doubling the volume of our business year
upon year GQ picked us as one of their
best new menswear designers in America
you've gotta be kidding
I think we tapped into a crowd of people
that were underrepresented in men's
clothing market and that's why we're
here